foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you were so wrong
[Music]
I heard you're not supposed to
clear your throat like that you know
I heard you're not supposed to do that
dude
what did I I can't I can't find some
good music man
I can't find the right music tonight
it's okay I mean it happens it's been a
while it's been a while welcome in
welcome in
oh my goodness I think like the second
the countdown hit zero Dr sherbet gifted
10 memberships
oh my goodness
so hold on we don't even need music for
right now
we don't even need music because
this is just gonna be going over and
over
we'll let this go for a bit Dr sherbet
thank you so much my friend for the 10
gifted memberships our first time
since the PlayStation showcase I think
was the last
the last stream that we did over here uh
on youtube.com
retro back and tour
and then right after Dr sherbet Let's
see we had Christy gifting out of
membership Christy thank you so much for
the gifted membership then we had Dylan
gifting out five
then we had Elwyn gifting out five then
we had Dustin gifting out five oh my
goodness they were all they were all
waiting for right when we went live
dude thank you guys so much Dr sherbet
Christy Dylan elwin and Dustin thank you
guys so much
very much appreciate it looks like Mrs
rack and tour got one of those gifted
memberships
she's being chief on me not choosing to
become a member on her own I'm just
kidding she probably didn't even realize
that it had uh lapsed
oh man
welcome in guys welcome in now Hagrid's
gonna take it away all right wait I
think we can bring the music back now
though
I think we can bring it back
yeah dude I had to hop on today and and
check all of the
yeah hold on we get just let me let me
let me get this music going
[Music]
chill wizard no let's try happy EDM
let's see what this is like we'll go
with this for a little bit
oh but yeah I had to hop on earlier
today to check all the alerts and
everything make sure everything was uh
set up correctly and most of it is
on your end I think we should be good
but on my end there are still some
things that don't look correctly it's
not letting me chat
in my own stream for some reason but
what can he do man what can he do you're
a wizard Harry
but yeah welcome into all of the new
members man it's been a while
since I've done this but house rack and
tour my friends
still going strong you just got one of
those gifted memberships you are now
officially part of housewrecking tour
guys
let's see whenever you're a member you
get access to our emotes you get a
special role in Discord which means
priority whenever we do our game nights
which
the first one was a big hit you guys
really enjoyed that so another one will
happen
will happen
oh dude thank you guys so much hold on
have I I need to scroll back up here
because
they're a wizard all right before we
even went live tonight I saw
[Music]
hold on let me scroll let me scroll here
you're a wizard before I even went live
I saw Dylan with the 12. dude that's one
year for Dylan which I think is the
maximum you're a wizard Harry that's
another thing you get like the little
loyalty badges I think the one that you
have Dylan I think that is the I don't
think I have one higher than that it's
just like it's like the logo with the
circle
around it sort of like a more of like a
medallion instead of just the the square
high IQ Warrior
had 10 months not far behind Dustin with
nine months nagura Ravenclaw was eight
months
Howie does it with seven months L win
with 10 months as well these were all
like before we even went live tonight
so I guess you guys re-upped in the lead
up to the Stream So Elwyn Howie nagura
Dustin hi IQ and Dylan before we even
got started tonight thank you guys so
much appreciate it
and then we had all those gifts that
just came in let me scroll up here make
sure we haven't missed any
it's like showing me so many that might
actually be
can Nike Craig Hollow Knight a new
member pilot Joseph with the four months
Drake okay I know Draco got one of the
gifts and Draco is at eight months okay
so all these are people that got one of
the gifts right there
I'm jzt new member welcome in pixie lady
with the three months Bradley Roberts
with the seven months zodiac with the
six months dude
all these like big time like long time
members now
I can't even believe it's been a year
that we've done like
I don't know I can't believe it's it's
in some ways it feels like more than a
year
but I've really only been streaming on
YouTube for like a year it's kind of
crazy right
we've been streaming on Twitch way
longer
okay so let's see we had Bradley with
the seven zodiac with the six Murphy
Aslan with the two months Chase with the
two months uh Cod King Black Ops with
the two curse Barkley with the two Jacob
Peterson
six-time member right here Ryan De La
Cruz Ryan welcome in that's three months
for Ryan four months for Tom so I think
all a lot of these were were gifteds
Christy gifted one let's see we got
Danielle got one of them Martin
king of games three three Hillary
Brothers Ryan Kingsbury in the house
Ryan what is up moonlace in the house
AKA Moon spark that's four months for
Ryan three months for Moon Spark
uh Joseph the Christian gamer Mrs
racketeur yes yes yes
Travis hammer with the five months
and then we had a Super Chat
from Dustin whoa I'm a red I'm a retro
baby
what does that mean Dustin what does
that mean
you're a retro baby
what does that mean
okay now now we gotta get to the chat
all right so the very first person I saw
dude our boy Rossi
oh how he does it he only occasionally
misses when we post a new video on
YouTube
but the vast majority of the time if you
guys go and check out any of our new
videos If you sort the comments by
actually I don't think they have a most
I think it's like newest so you'd have
to go all the way yeah if you go and
look at the comment that was the first
comment
I would say about ninety percent of the
time it's it's Rossi Rossi also first
in the live stream as soon as we posted
it man like the countdown like not our
10 minute countdown the countdown when I
first posted it this afternoon
oh and then Christy was a very close
second
Christie was real excited for this
your Tweet cracked me up he's back
he's back
my wife and I crack up at that part of
the movie every time
just the the actor the expression on his
it always makes my wife mad because
she's like duh they try to tell you
fudge come on fudge
just like the eyes he's back
is like yeah I know I'm probably out of
a job pretty soon
uh Terence Clark welcome in Lauren
Garcia Cloud Roth
Chrissy elwin uh let's see we already
shouted out Dr sherbet in the house did
I say Lauren Lauren as well Anna stopped
by for a minute
oh thank you Anna for stopping by and
saying hello if you watch this later see
this on the VOD I know she had to leave
and is in a time zone that is way ahead
of us so these late night streams I mean
they're not late night for me but yeah
they don't work work well for Anna
uh okay Dr sherbet I'm just now getting
to read your comment this this could be
one of those nights you guys
if you're new here and you're like bro
he's so far behind bro come on bro read
your read your chat bro
you know it just you just got
ta look look like get get you a nice
chair here's here's what we do
here's what we do here at house tracking
tour you know you can get you a
comfortable chair
grab some popcorn get yourself some
snacks chat knows like the regulars they
know I've always got my snack locked in
I've got my beverage here of choice
I don't think you guys will be able to
guess this one this is a different
flavor Waterloo a flavor that I
honestly would not expect me to enjoy
but I really like it
I'll show you guys let me show you guys
right here
I don't think anybody will guess it so
I'm just gonna show you
Blackberry lemonade
not sponsored not sponsored
and it is
very tasty like I'm not a fan of I don't
really eat blackberries but it's good
all right so now that you're all relaxed
and I'm even further behind but now now
you know what you're in for you're here
you're here for the ride
it's gonna be a it's gonna be a fun
night we got a lot to talk about we got
a lot to go over we got a lot to catch
up on
you guys are like okay is he ever gonna
is he is he gonna like is he gonna start
reading
all right here we go so Dr sherbet with
the eight months had a comment along
with it as well I still remember to this
day when I went through the YouTube
algorithm and found not just you but so
many other great and wonderful people Dr
shurit thank you so much we are glad you
found this as well moderator here
and on the Discord as well
but yeah it's it really is crazy I wish
I could remember like the first time
that I watched
certain people's video like James and
stuff like the first time I saw one of
his videos
and then the first time we connected and
stuff
which has he
yeah I think he's announced this
he's announced that we're gonna be doing
a little uh
little get together at least virtually
I'm not I don't want to give if he is if
he hasn't fully announced it
but yeah just just keep an eye on uh
keep an eye on everybody expecto goes
things
gonna be joining him uh later this week
for a live stream discussion
as well as some other guests so
and we didn't even know about this uh
Magic waking stuff at the time so
that'll give us even more to talk about
all right Cloud Roth with the four
months as well
all right let me make sure I said hello
to everyone pilot Joseph I see you in
the chat
Dustin I see you in the chat as well jzt
also in the chat all right we're rolling
now guys we're rolling Hollow Knight
Craig
icon Nike Jacob Tom these are basically
all the people that got the subs in the
chat
Blue Moon Blue Moon oh my goodness
there's a name I haven't seen in a while
welcome in Blue Moon good to see you
good to see you
uh Bradley did I say hello to Bradley if
I didn't Bradley hello welcome in
welcome him
five petition to water to sponsor retro
mods a symbol dude that'd be a pretty
cool sponsorship honestly
Chrissy thank you so much for the five
yeah I've always heard people say like
who would your dream
sponsors be I mean aside from like the
you know the really big ones
a lot of the really big ones don't even
do
a ton of sponsorships but yeah Waterloo
would be nice
we drink it a lot already on stream
they're probably we don't need to
sponsor you you're already you're
already promoting it
um
okay let's see who else do we have here
Jenny AKA Damia one another moderator
here in the house welcome in Jenny
dude where is I'm trying to find Dylan's
name in the chat because I want to see
what his oh when I'm looking at it Dylan
it still shows the gold the gold uh are
maybe I haven't changed it on YouTube
yet
because I thought I had made it to where
like the final one was a a circle it's
like just the main like the main logo
the blue one
stormy welcome in sick but here oh no
sorry to hear that astral night Teen
Wolf Maniac so many gifted Subs
right I mean apparently astral you just
have to go away for a little bit and
then come back and your community is
like welcome back we missed you come on
in
come on come on over
um
oh my too Shar that's a name I haven't
seen before welcome in good to see you
yes I saw it Dr sherbet I found it I
found it
astral night I just saw your other
comment about you've pre-registered for
the game but you still don't really know
how it works you play Kingdom Hearts
chain of Memories and looked
and looked it so I should be good
well we're gonna go over all that
tonight because I'm kind of in the same
boat and I'll I'll tell you guys why I
think the marketing on this game has
been a little bit
confusing
I think there's I think there's a good
reason for that I think there's a good
reason
jzt 100
incredibly generous incredibly
incredibly generous
nine months for you Dustin as well let's
go
uh also another name he he ansio welcome
in welcome in Logan how's it going Logan
thank you for being here
Drake dude Draco
how many of you have played
Harry Potter magic awakened for more
than like three hours
because Draco in the house
knows a lot about this game Draco has
played it extensively
and of all the people like in the
community that I you know that we like
chat with online and stuff
draco's been following the stream for a
while and
Draco knows a lot about this game so
Draco I don't know how long you got
tonight but if you're here for most of
the stream we might have a lot of
questions for you anybody else in that
same boat though we can ask you as well
because it's kind of weird because it's
been it's been playable in a lot of
territory territories but then they've
also made various updates they're still
I still have a lot of questions but I
haven't even watched the new the new
trailer yet and it's like the longest
one yet so I want to check that out
oh you guys were close with the
blueberry guesses very close
all right we're almost caught up we are
almost caught up
start with Waterloo then move on to
PlayStation yeah yeah
badge Quest gaming uh oh my goodness
dude it just it puts a smile on my face
when I see so many of the uh
just like the people that were here week
after week man
you guys already know who you are
we had
I don't know dude it's just like didn't
I did I not tell you guys when we were
going through
the build up to Hogwarts Legacy I was
just like Savor this
Savor this moment because it won't be
the same
after
I'm gonna quit streaming you guys didn't
know you had no idea no but just like it
like when you have something big like
that to look forward to
hype I just love hype man I'm not one of
those people who's like
I must not get hyped
I'm like dude let's let's just get hyped
Let's Go All In
so to see so many of those names it
means a lot
Draco It looks interesting for sure
14 months now for Draco
Ginny okay yeah I knew I know L one's
played a little bit too
Jenny's played more than a few hours
but you still have a million questions
gotcha
Lauren you haven't heard
Lauren you're not the only one you're
not the only one
I did a poll
let me find this so you guys know I mean
our
a big chunk of our audience is
Wizarding World focused right
so I knew there was an issue with
with the awareness
of this game back on let's see
on June 3rd
let's go ahead and switch views actually
let's see if this fingers crossed let's
let's hope this works let's let's hope
foreign
[Music]
yes
love it when a plan comes together
yeah I'm still not feeling this music
let's go back to the chill
they do have one called surprise me
but I feel like we just need yeah we
need need a little more
low-key now just kind of subtle in the
background
all right so I posted this poll right
here
have you heard just have you heard of
Harry Potter magic awakened now remember
a lot of people seeing this there's
going to be some people who don't follow
us regularly
but a lot of the people seeing this poll
most likely started following us for
Hogwarts Legacy stuff we had almost 7
500 votes and look at this man 76 said
no
they hadn't even heard of it
and so I said we would get to it I think
it's because the
the game was actually developed
by netease
which is not a us-based company I'm
pretty sure they're in China
um
and so another thing that's made it
really weird is there are like multiple
official accounts I actually reached out
to one of their the US representatives
about a week or two ago just to say like
okay
are these are these legit
um
because this one here like the the CeeLo
Harry Potter Harry Potter magic awakened
community
I don't think that one is
officially actually it might be it might
be
because they had this post today
finally on June 27th Harry Potter
magical bacon will be launched worldwide
I thank you for the long time waiting we
are looking forward to going on this
magical adventure with you soon
and then they link to
this YouTube channel right here
Harry Potter magic awaken Community 22
000 subscribers
hold on let me see something here
everything about so yeah their their
location is Brazil
but anyway this is not like the official
US account I mean clearly they're
Affiliated somehow so I think there's a
lot of territorial differences in terms
of the marketing teams
so a lot of times you're getting
official news
but it's from different sources so with
Hogwarts Legacy it was like it was
really clear to know oh this is coming
from Avalanche right I mean Chandler
tweeted this it's like this is the
website magicawaken.com and you know you
can see the WB right here so this is
like the Us website
but then if you scroll down
look right here for more information
about Harry Potter magic awaken please
visit
harrypottermagicawaken.com so then you
go here
and then it's like a completely
different website
this is the global website
so I think that's part of it is it's
been it's been a little unclear for
people on like
what exactly this game is is it mobile
because some people are saying it's PC
we're gonna try to clear all that up
tonight as much as we can
um
as much as we can we're gonna try to
clear that up let me go back here to the
other
thank you
dude I'm just like none of these none of
this music man
foreign
none of it's working for me tonight
[Music]
but yeah Draco is played a lot just
purchased an iPad Pro to play it at work
oh my gosh are you serious
let's go
will the Chromebook be able to run it
okay here's another here's a cool thing
if you are on
if you have an apple if you have a Mac
and it's one of the
CH uh one of the MacBooks with an m
hold on hold on let me back up
if you have an Apple computer
and it's one of the newer-ish ones that
has an actual
Apple chip in it and not an Intel chip
it can actually run any iPhone or iPad
app it's pretty cool
so that is currently my plan if it
doesn't
come over to PC
there's some mixed messaging going on
with with PC
when it's officially playable on PC
for everyone
there is a PC client like there is a a
confirmed PC client
and I've seen some I think it was
actually you Draco I saw on the Discord
saying that
you saw somewhere where it is gonna be
ready for the global launch
but in all the marketing materials I'm
seeing from the US team of magic awaken
it doesn't mention any
anything about the PC version
expect to go in the house yo what's up
expecto go welcome in welcome in
Christy thank you so much for the two
appreciate it
it's not official is that the PC thing
um
James is that what you're talking about
because
James and I have access to a uh like
this WB press site where they put like
their press releases and stuff and so
there's one on there
that is like a magic awakened fact sheet
basically
like more extensively than what you get
here on the website right here
and it doesn't say anything about the PC
version
so we shall see
we shall see
the Twitter page that one's not official
gotcha okay
so yeah the the c e l o one
is not official this one right here
this one right here
is official this one is official
that one is the official US
site right there
oh yeah and then here's the other thing
I was gonna check let's see if you hit
this YouTube page right here
yeah okay see
we've got a third YouTube page let's
enter the picture
so we know this one's official so this
is the global site and then if you hit
their YouTube page look where it takes
you it takes you to this one Harry
Potter magic awakened s-e-a
the sea magic awakened page
so they also upload videos sometimes
different videos than what
the US One uploads so I think that's a
big part for the confusion so like watch
this if you're we're on the US site now
if you hit their YouTube link
it takes you to this one HP magic
awakened no SCA
at the end of it but then today I saw
they posted like all the different
languages it's very confusing it's very
very confusing
but that's what we're gonna try to do
tonight let's clear all that up
by the way James I was asking earlier is
the uh is the thing later this week that
that we're doing together you announced
that right
I know I saw it in Discord somewhere but
I couldn't remember if I'd seen you
tweeted or anything
I was just telling everybody to stay
tuned for later this week that uh you
and I might be getting together again
for for a little something fun
Brittany in the house as well Brittany
what is up I'll wait and let James uh
confirm I don't want to um overstep if
I'm wrong
no Early Access okay guys you're in the
early you're in the Early Access group
right now
it's not like official official it's
official for like our Early Access
people
so that can be you since you're here
so yeah I told him I was like keep an
eye on uh James's socials and everything
keep an eye keep an eye
and James thank you so much for the nine
months too appreciate it man get ready
to live in The Wizarding World With
Friends uh yes Thursday not announced
yet Early Access gotcha gotcha
so yeah stay tuned guys stay tuned
ah this Thursday
yeah I was saying oh when you've been
playing a little bit as well
Peter what is this game first time
hearing about it
right all right
this is what this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna I I went the other day and I
watched through every one of their
videos that they had posted here but
first we're gonna read the official
announcement
then we're gonna watch the newest
trailer
so just off off the Jump
since we have we've already had a couple
people saying what is this I've never
heard of it let me go ahead and cut the
music right here because I'm I'm just
none of this music man it's just not
it's not hitting for me tonight sorry
just have to listen to my voice
so let's start off from the top of this
one right here what is Harry Potter
magic awakened
Harry Potter magic Awakening is an
immersive collectible card game and
massively multiplayer
wait the MMO threw me off it didn't have
online in there and massively
multiplayer Wizarding dueling game
that's interesting way of describing It
featuring a blend of strategy Role Play
Elements players will take on a role of
a first year student in Hogwarts joining
thousands of other witches and wizards
in a quest to master their magic so
in a sense it is an MMO
but it is not like third person action
in the in the vein of like a Hogwarts
Legacy
collectible card game now but just to
just to get out of the way it is a free
to play micro transaction game yes and
it is primarily a mobile game for iOS
and Google Play
there is a PC client
and you there are also ways that you can
run it on PC Through official emulators
so a lot of times people hear emulator
and they think like oh you know I don't
want to dabble in that
but the company that makes the game
netease they actually have their own
emulator for it which I
this is another conversation entirely
but I downloaded it and could not could
not get it to work properly but anyway
if you if you're like dead set on like I
want to play it on PC even if the
official PC client isn't out there are
official PC emulators I know makes makes
perfect sense right
so that's just kind of overall what it
is who's the publisher Warner Brothers
and Eddie's games under the portkey
games label who is the developer
co-developed by Warner Brothers games
and netease games under the port key
games label I don't even think they've
updated this yet yeah they haven't even
updated this with uh today's news
because it's already been out in a lot
of other territories so that's why
you're seeing some people in the chat
saying they've played it others saying
they've had they haven't
and so remember we're on the U.S site
here's what it says on which platform
will the game be available on magical
bacon will be available for free
download on the App Store and Google
Play for mobile devices all right now
I'm not going to read all these because
I don't think
yeah we've read a lot of these before
they're basically the same ones that
they were
for Hogwarts Legacy all right so here's
the big announcement today let's go back
back here
here was the big announcement this was
just made today Harry Potter magic
awakens the launched worldwide on June
27th so we are officially one week away
guys one week away
and it's free to play man so I mean you
might as well
download it try it give it a shot
I am not I will say this I am not
typically a mobile gamer I do not play a
lot of games on my phone anymore at all
like
hardly ever do I play anything on my
phone
um but this I'm gonna try it out like I
said I'm going to try it out on my I
have a MacBook Air I'm going to try to
play it on that and see how it goes and
I'm not one who spins on
microtransactions either so I will
review this game and talk about this
game from the perspective of someone
trying not to spend a lot of money on
microtransactions I mean I shouldn't say
I'm not going to but I don't typically
do that uh now I was talking to Draco
about this
um so I was like how how heavy are the
micro transactions
and the way Draco was describing it is
that
if you want to be one of the top duelers
in the game like you want to be because
it does have like a PVP you know dueling
in the game then it is kind of pay to
win in that sense like you can get more
cards
by paying for the micro transactions in
the game and then you're going to get
more powerful spells so you can earn
those and you will earn those in the
game free you know naturally just by
playing
but sounds like you can just unlock them
a lot faster if you if you want to pay
so
I'm curious to get in and see for myself
you know like how
how egregious or you know if it's if
it's pretty well balanced hopefully it
is yeah you know I know when um Hogwarts
mystery came out it was
it had a had a really rough start of
people complaining about the micro
transactions and they actually ended up
uh changing it for that game so a lot of
people still think that I mean that game
has micro transactions too but um yeah
they actually made it a lot better A lot
better than it was initially
so all right here's the official
announcement from today this highly
anticipated free to play collectible
card role-playing game will be available
for IOS and Android devices players are
invited to pre-register now to receive
exclusive rewards once the title is
released so we actually we already have
a video up about this on the channel
um but if you haven't done this yet
which a lot of you were saying you
haven't heard of the game
um
it's so weird how like YouTube YouTube's
algorithm works sometimes because if you
were following me you think it would
have notified you guys
um so just a few weeks ago we had
this right here do this before the new
Harry Potter game releases so this is
the one that walks you through how you
can uh go ahead and pre-register and you
see they've got this little meter right
here I would say this is going to jump
up
hopefully to 5 million considering that
they've made the announcement that we uh
that it's launching next week so
hopefully in a few days that will jump
up to five and who knows maybe by the
launch date we can get it up to eight
they don't even show us what the reward
is
but yeah right now just for signing up
you're gonna get baby mant cores and a
niffler card pack Nimbus 2000 plus 1000
gold 10 Silver Keys plus 1500 gold 100
gems plus two thousand gold and then
golden key plus 50 gems
James have a good one dude thank you for
being here have a fun and amazing stream
got a pod to do hit the like button and
retro
hey James did give us like a crash
course on his last dream
he did indeed
James thank you for stopping by dude
good to see you have a good one
no no no it is not it is not the
Quidditch game
there are two two new Harry Potter games
releasing this year yeah so this one
quidditch Champions that is developed by
a completely separate team if you're
wondering why there's not been a lot of
conversation around that game this is
the video for you to check out right
here
um just to sum it up NDA NDA there's a
lot of people who have gotten to play
that well I say a lot I don't know if
it's actually a lot but they've done
three play tests now we know that and
anyone who participated in the play test
can't talk about what they played can't
talk about what they've seen
so that's why I think you haven't seen
as much discussion around that game but
that is happening I don't actually know
they haven't said anything about when
that game is going to release so
my guess I think that's also going to be
a free-to-play game but we don't know
for sure the biggest difference here is
this is a console game right here and PC
so magic awake and more of a mobile
focused title and also PC as well
all right so Draco give us give us the
quick rundown here of
if you're still here just as as easy as
easy as you can make this
how how valuable are these things right
here
because I'm trying I'm trying to like
okay so in this game you're gonna be
collecting cards
and it's my understanding that those
cards you use them in your battles
throughout the game
some of the cards you can see here is a
niffler you have another card that's a
baby Manticore then you can also get
cards like Snape and Harry Potter that
will do special attacks then you also
have cards that are spells
so what I want to know let's look at
let's look and see how many currencies
we have here okay we have a we have gold
as a currency
we have silver keys
we have gems and we have golden keys
that's a lot of currencies man
that's a lot of currencies
that is a whole lot of currencies right
here
but yeah I feel like there have been so
many people who were um
just not aware of this game so I'm I'm
working on I'm getting more videos ready
um which now I need to speed up on that
since the game is officially coming out
next week
not very valuable okay see a new Draco
would be honest with us not very
valuable to be honest you will get more
than that in your first week just going
through the story oh man I kind of I
kind of expected that you know
because we're all everybody's just
looking at this like yes let's let's get
the gyms come on
what do you use the gyms for does
anybody know what do you what are you
using for
Keys likely unlock chess containing
special cards that's another Fair Point
right because I guess things could
technically change
since the version you guys have been
playing is not like the final version
but but then again games like this that
are always online
which I mean you don't put this amount
of time and effort into something like
this unless you wanted to hang around
for a while
so I mean I would think that they're
going to try and support this game for a
number of years you would hope depending
on how well how well it does
oh that was Dr sherbet who said Keys
likely unlock chests containing special
cards so yeah we've got but we've got
Silver Keys though and then we have
golden keys then we also have gyms and
then we also have gold
so I'm trying to keep track of all these
different currencies here
keys are for card pulls okay
now for anyone who's played it
are there different tiers of cards like
the the niffler and the manticores here
they have kind of like this purple
outline around them
so would would the cards for like Harry
Potter be that same level or are they
going to be a higher or lower tier
Jenny said gold equals battle better
cards
gold keys that is and then Draco says
Keys give you cards for your deck okay
so we got the 10 Silver Keys we've got a
golden key through this thing here well
if we reach that which we haven't
reached that yet but all right so keys
are how you're going to get more cards
silver keys are for normal cards rare
cards and witching
20 cards you are guaranteed an epic card
uh okay so they do have like kind of
that tiered system so we've got normal
rare and then epic is it three
categories there
uh let's see
silver keys are for lower Rarity gold
for more rare gotcha Silver Keys you get
a couple draws gold gives you more draws
with why am I having draws draws why am
I having a hard time saying that gold
gives you more draws with I think better
odds get better cards
Dustin I'm assuming you can play it oh
that's a good question Dustin yeah like
is there any are there any sort of time
time Gates
because typically that is
one of the frustrating things about
these types of games is that yeah you
can you can you can play as much as you
want but you can only earn so many gems
or keys or whatever in a you know
however many hour span
if you played Hearthstone or MTG went
it'll have similar mechanics oh you're
asking if it'll have no time Gates
that's good that is good news common
rare epic and legendary gotcha okay so
like the traditional
like the traditional that's awesome
though no time Gates let's go
but I would say if you oh man it's Gotta
It's gotta get pretty grindy though if
you want to try and not spend anything
at all like not do any micro
transactions all right let's uh let's go
back here and let's watch this trailer
because there's another thing I want to
clarify
oh wait wait wait wait wait
let's go uh let's go full screen let's
make sure we're watching it at the
highest quality here
crank up the volume for you guys all
right so this is a Harry Potter magic
awakened official Gameplay trailer
[Music]
hello
that's right
you're in a steady matching
I don't care what anybody says dude I
love the art style I think the RSL is so
good
you've been invited to this wondrous
place to master magical skills
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go back and watch it
again
I don't want to do the stop thing right
now
Advanced potion making
learn powerful charms
and study all manner of Fantastic Beasts
this is a hypocrite
don't know how I feel about the
hippogriff
jump like the style I
am
promise
oh my gosh the wolves look
well they looked awesome lots of work to
do make sure you find time to play
Quidditch is in the game
and Forge New bonds why don't we dance
together
[Music]
we've got some like Elite beat agents
going on I will be your eyes around
every corner and your ears where you
cannot hear how Dreadful
[Music]
come try out this one
I'm so disappointed with the wand which
you can already get your wand right now
you'll learn to become the best witch or
wizard you can be while sharing oh okay
this is a lot of
info right there
I want to pause it so bad but we're
gonna we're gonna watch it through the
first time
[Music]
but before you wield your won't
you must develop different strategies
Dumbledore the water spell man
[Music]
[Applause]
and find The Power Within to take on any
challenge
oh I was hoping they would show this
book no name
favorite characters yeah they're cool
and overcome that's really cool I like
that no you
exciting stories and
with your own Adventures to unfold does
anyone know what happened to Ivy I
believe a search party is in order so
grab your wound
[Music]
join the community of witches and
wizards
and prepare to master the magic
let's go dude
June 27 download for free and Play app
store or Google play yet nothing about
PC man
come on
all right so I mentioned earlier that I
I took a day I don't know a week or two
ago and watched every single one of
these and on the uh the sea one as well
let's see where is it this one I watched
all of these that trailer that we just
watched by far the best one they've done
so far
by far the best one
we're gonna watch it again here in a
second
all right I want to catch up with the uh
put the comments here
um
there was one I wanted to
somebody you guys were saying something
about the uh
okay so yeah Drago said No Time Gates
like energy in the game but activities
like dancing and quidditch only happen
so many times a day okay
and then uh two two one
I'm so sorry I'm not sure how to
pronounce your name but thank you so
much for your comments and clarifying
this for us here no time Gates but
there's a cap of free currency that you
can earn in a day
so yeah that's that's to be expected I
think
uh Draco I've played the game on
weekends for over eight hours straight
oh my goodness
insert whatever to get random stuff is
grindy true but I played a lot of
Destiny man and I didn't mind it at all
I didn't mind it
uh Draco also said Dustin this game is
just like any gotcha very grindy okay so
yeah I mean I think as long as people
kind of know
what you're getting into right
so it is going to be a more grinded out
type of game it's it's definitely not a
not a game like in the vein of Hogwarts
Legacy at all
you will have a few ones what
how do they work that into the lore not
that I'm complaining because if you get
if you guys go online and do the uh the
if you watch my video about the
pre-registering and all that do this
before it releases you can also go ahead
and get your wand now and it asks
I was so disappointed man it asked like
three questions that ask your email
address
name and then pick your favorite color
I was like what what
you would think it would like read from
the Wizarding World nah it just I don't
know if it's randomized randomized if
it's based on
the email character somehow color I have
no idea but the wand is is not at all
anywhere close to the wand I actually
have on Wizarding World so
what can you say
what can you say but apparently
according to Draco here we're going to
be able to uh
to get different different ones anyway
yeah I'm intrigued by it I'm intrigued
like I said I am not typically a mobile
gamer anything Wizarding World related
though I'm gonna give it a try I I'm
gonna give it a try and okay here's what
I wanted to stop this and say the fact
that we can play this together you guys
that's huge man that is huge I think to
this day I still get comments from
people about Hogwarts Legacy saying like
they need to add a multiplayer mode they
need to add Co-op
so many people that are fans of The
Wizarding World want to group up
together
as a party as a team and go in and do
these Adventures of quests and this game
lets you do it which we saw a couple of
occasions here there were a couple of
spots in there where you could actually
see people uh
text or chatting back and forth through
text CAD Bane gotta go have a good
stream hey appreciate it dude thank you
for stopping by you can always catch the
rest on the replay later all good
Anthony is here working on your own
video game yo congrats dude let's go
what kind of game are you working on
Anthony
you've been playing daily for one to two
months wands give a bonus extra revive
faster energy region Etc okay so they're
kind of like
they're not really adhering to the lore
they're they're playing around a little
bit there with the lore
which you know
yeah no sometimes you gotta you gotta
maneuver things around to make it work
oh that's a good question Lauren do you
lose cards once you use it are they gone
the moment you use them
and then Draco says uh they have a wheel
each month that has different outfits
that have really nice looking effects
and new wands it's so costly you won't
try to play it at oh interesting
you have to save up huh you pay for each
spin of the wheel
gotcha
astronaut your favorite color is green
but you're red cool so you picked blue
just in case I thought the same thing my
favorite color is blue but I am
Gryffindor I kind of froze up at that
part I was like wait a second is this is
it actually soaring me here or is this
just related to the wand
high IQ warrior in the house as well hi
IQ what is up welcome in welcome in I
saw you by the way before we even went
live re-upped uh your membership high IQ
Warrior I think it was like nine months
or something 10 months it's up there
dude thank you so much for all your
support
all right let's watch this again
let's watch this again here because I
there's a lot of stuff that I wanted to
stop and comment on but I just didn't
want to be annoying as we were going
through it
all right so Harry Potter magic
Awakening official Gameplay trailer
oh yeah so I love the fact that you can
relive some of the original
biggest scenes from the original books I
think that's cool they called it the
book of no name or something
so you get Harry Potter right there
Dumbledore with Fox the trio
hello no ah this is so Hagrid arrives to
to pick us up just like with Harry
and a steady matching
[Music]
welcome young witches and wizards to
your first year at Hogwarts
Okay
so we've got wait is that Harry right
there what
quick pause quick pause let's go to the
FAQ
because I think
uh is this where it answers
oh man where does it answer there's some
place that tells you when the game takes
place which I'm pretty sure it's like 10
years after
Harry defeats Voldemort he's like when
we're we're going to school so a lot of
the faces
will be the same but like Neville's
teaching herbology for example there's a
different defense against the dark arts
professor
um but mcgonagall's the headmistress he
still got Hagrid there of course
right here okay
all right so you see on the cards here
you've got like level one on all of
these
and slightly different color coding so
this one's kind of got like a grayish
blue this one's more of a brown
a purple on this one that's a level two
so I wonder what these num I'm sure the
game is going to have a tutorial for all
of this that teaches you the ropes of
this
but I still want to try and piece a lot
of it together as much as I can by going
back
you pick a deck of 10 cards that you
cycle through during a duel cards cost
energy to play upgrade cards by
collecting more copies to make them
higher level and stronger
whoa interesting
okay so you don't
oh man so like once you unlock a card
it will sort of stay in my collection
forever
is how I'm understanding that and then I
I can collect more of that same card to
like
to upgrade it
Ah that's interesting
you're working on an open world RPG
let's go
dude that's awesome Anthony love to hear
it man
love to hear it good luck with that
yes you upgrade your cards as you go in
turn that levels up your spell book okay
okay
so this level four one it looks like it
is a
oh what did we call them legendary epic
common
I'm already forgetting
um but but it's also like a level four
all right okay
okay let's stop this right here okay so
that's a rare one so rare times one
you've got the blue that's agua minty
and it's got a five right there so
damage of four wait really augmenti does
four damage
foreign
that's kind of uh surprising
continuously sprays a total of 10 Jets
of water in a straight line the line of
attack can be adjusted by moving while
casting each time a jet of water hits
the same enemy the damage it deals
increases is what I'm guessing that says
number at the top left is how much it
costs to play okay it's a wondrous place
so that's how much it costs to play
right here we got like our three our
five four four two three three three
awesome magical all right
[Music]
Sibley Rose okay and then it looks like
we're confronting a troll in the
bathroom
thought you ought to know
um and so then you've got so can you
only hold a certain amount of cards at a
time like these three right here
oh nope more just popped up into the
deck here
let's watch that again
so they use Stupify
all right class now hey there's a voice
Slughorn
train against the darker that is the
defense against the dark arts teacher
which I've seen the name of them
somewhere I can't remember the exact
name
foreign
levels to your cards but the big number
five means takes five Mana to cast okay
gotcha that's what uh two on was saying
as well
for the big question can we have a team
Guild oh ABS yeah absolutely we need we
need to make up once once it's out and I
can figure out how to do it yeah
absolutely
team and a dorm praying against the dark
odds
got uh Bogarts
still teaching charms
and study all manner A Fantastic Beasts
this is a hypocrite
[Music]
but take heed for danger lurks just
beyond the school grounds I want to go
into the Forbidden Forum okay I know a
big part of the story is about Ivy and
she goes missing and that's like what
what the main storyline is about our
main character and I'm assuming this
this person right here I can't remember
his name it'll be fine I promise
yo we got dragons and dude look at these
wolves right here though
oh my goodness and then we've got this
times 55 over here
goofy is why it took so long to release
in the US I know right
I know I mean I I think they've been
making a lot of tweaks and changes to
the game but yeah it is kind of baffling
that it
that the US and UK were among like the
last the last ones
just remember when it comes to dorm
rooms they have four people in the dorm
and all four have to be the same gender
and from the same house
to be in a dorm okay gotcha
need to all be on a team and call it
retro Recon tour oh we gotta call it
It's gotta be like house wrecking tour
right
we got to be team house reckon tour
the times 55 is your movement cards
movement cards
what does that mean exactly oh wait two
ones got it for us move cards limits the
number of moves that you can make
whoa okay this is gonna be yeah
it's going to be a big learning curve
just starting out in this game but yeah
I'm really I'm digging the design on
these werewolves right here just cast
incendio right there
all right it's just a tad loud well
there may be a lot of work to do make
sure you find time to Quidditch
is in the game
[Music]
to forge new bombs why don't we dance
together
your ball in the game dude I actually
love these kind of Rhythm games like
this
Elite beat agents on the Nintendo DS oh
I love that game
I love that game so much with friends
you can always rely on I will be your
eyes around every corner and your ears
[Music]
come try out this one
okay let's let's freeze it on this right
here
I'm I'm pretty sure there's a lot of
customization options for the your look
and what you're wearing so let's see we
got one two three four over here on the
right and then looks like clothing right
there
oh look at all this dude
and then all these categories over here
on the left you will learn to become the
best Witcher
got the hats right here looks like
hairstyles right here
wizard you can be
oh dude you can change out your dorm too
I didn't even know about this actually
heavy draperies capable of blocking out
even the harshest sunlight perfect for
sleeping in after a night of exciting
games I love it
this almost reminds me like uh kind of
like rumor requirement in Hogwarts
Legacy with the wizard you can be a
little extra customization okay this
right here
we all love Hagrid oh I saw you guys
showing Hagrid some love earlier
we got Riley The Chosen One Anthony
Nana
so this is like some sort of in-game
follow home follow group and my news
huh these almost look like little
are these like little up little posts
that you can make and only see in game
sort of like an in-game Forum or chat or
something
it's not AAA game like Hogwarts
wondering if there was some boardy chess
oh like trying to set up all the player
counts or something oh I see what you
mean who knows maybe
[Music]
Draco said when you were in a duel or
even in the force you can only move so
many times that's part of the strategy
okay so it what do you what do you guys
mean exactly by move though because like
the way it looked right there
it's like you're just doing battle
when you say move would me like casting
incendio does that does that count as a
move or are you talking like physically
moving around
like you can only go over this much
space I guess is what I'm getting at
moving around the board okay
it's like a chat room sort of like
Discord in-game gotcha
I know when when somebody makes posts
there and hey it got 286 thumbs up too
unless they just you know faked this
which is possible
and then you've got where you can add
friends right here please enter a name
or the ID number
that's kind of cool
experiences and in this I don't know how
this I guess it's like an in-game chat
be careful and follow me this will be
over in a bit what about uh do they have
in-game voice chat or do you have to
just like use Discord or something if
you want to voice chat
Great Hall over here
[Music]
dude you gotta love the niflers man you
gotta love the nifflers all right so
then we have dueling top wizard solo
best Partners Duo so the way I
understand it this this gets pretty
competitive because this is a PVP thing
right here
and a lot of people get really into this
really into this
in-game voice chat and text chat very
nice very nice
okay so I'm
that's good that's good to know inter
practice match with a companion so you
can do Duos or just solos
are you here oh man
look at these NPCs
[Music]
oh wait we gotta go back to that page
oh my gosh look at Voldemort right there
fiend fire
are you serious yeah that better be Max
damage
okay this right here they flipped over
this one really quick
oh that's fiend fire right there
oh look at that
dude you know what they should actually
sell physical versions of these cards
they would sell so many of these
looks like Voldemort again on that card
right there
okay so there's the fiend fire someone's
fiend fire that shoots fire at opponents
units to deal damage
and then it has something called front
row right here
not sure what that's about the damage of
course is five rating of five that's
expected
oh oh it's just called orb of water
thunderstorm someone's a Thunderbird
okay see that's where I'm fine with like
yeah throw out the lore does this does
this kind of thing happen in in the real
world no but it's gonna look pretty cool
in the game
some of the Thunderbird to call upon a
thunderstorm that casts 15 random bolts
I'm surprised it's only a damage of
three though maybe because it's it's
like kind of sporadic and spread out
laughs
it's not toxic but it's very competitive
pretty sure you'll be a novice Dueler
forever No Nonsense
hey but you don't have to I don't think
you have to really go into the dueling
to enjoy the game at least I hope not
I mean I probably will but I don't think
it's like
I don't think it's like the main
well I guess for some people it is some
people get really into it it is like the
main focus
I remember that Logan I had some of
those cards yes
I had some of those cards and I don't
even know what happened to them
I think I gave them all away or
something but
or sold them or probably threw them away
recycled them or something
so then we got orb of water and look
they even show it show the moment
Dumbledore casting it on Voldemort I
love that control so it has this other
uh little category as well
three on that damage of four casts orb
of water drawing in all opponents units
within range and dealing
I assume damage we can't see only then
can you sharpen your dueling skills
spiders
oh I think that's that's Hermione right
there isn't it Hermione's card
next it's a Duo duel
this looks very there's a lot going on
oh I saw a combo thing over here on the
left combo of six
whoa okay a lot happening a lot
happening we do have spiders Dr sherbet
spiders are in the game
oh my gosh there's
what is this Aunt Marge down here
no way there's a card with ant Marge on
there
that is too funny oh you know it Draco
we got it we gotta stream some of this
yes
inflatus
that is too funny and find The Power
Within to take on any challenge
atmosphere charm is that what she said
okay yeah now this
there was a lot of confusion I feel like
from fans when they first started
showing trailers because we were seeing
scenes of like
a totally news story but then we were
also seeing scenes like the Basilisk in
the Chamber of Secrets and some of the
iconic scenes with Harry Ron Hermione so
there is something in game they're about
to tell us called The Book Of No Name I
believe
and I guess these are I don't know if
you have access to it right at the
beginning or if it's something you earn
as you progress but you'll basically be
able to go back and play through some of
the biggest moments from the series as
Harry Ron Hermione let's see how exactly
they worded here
open the book with no name and become oh
dude look at those cards too you got
Harry playing quidditch looks like Draco
over here
that must be
um
that must be the scene from Deathly
Hallows don't you think and Gringotts
and Hermione over here another Harry
card I'm guessing that's Ron right there
maybe McGonagall over there sorry
Hermione and other favorite whoa wait
did you see that
was that wormtail lurking in the
background
oh my gosh look at him
I did not even catch that the first time
oh dude look at him man see like I just
it's totally different spin on like the
design but I I really do dig the design
the art style of a lot of this and our
favorite characters I mean
so the chess match prisoner basket
fighting story s and experiences that
made them celebrated Heroes it's time
for your own Adventures to unfold does
anyone know what happened to Ivy I
believe a search party is in order okay
so see now we're back to like present
day magana was talking about where is
Ivy search party in order
foreign
[Music]
we've got did you guys see that look at
that we've got the Christmas decorations
got the Snowman got the lights here join
the community of witches and
what is that nasal
a stag and then uh Pixie right there
there's the Pixies again
oh another Dragon right there at the end
I'm intrigued man I'm looking forward to
trying it out for sure let me know in
the comments Below guys if you want to
try this out
as always thank you all so much for
watching talk to you again soon that's
just for our YouTube video that we'll
post later don't worry we're not we're
not ending this dream
just ending my recording that's all
spiders I know right
follow the spiders
the spiders are back lots of spiders
Draco says
oh kind of like the the Thunder Brew in
Hogwarts Legacy yeah a little bit
except this one summons an actual
Thunderbird apparently
whenever this game will put players in
Azkaban for Cheating in the game
lately the trend for antichi and
multiplayer games is to humiliate
cheaters
that would that would actually be
hilarious
that would be hilarious
yo Jake what's up welcome in dude how's
it going
dude what the heck why is
that is a creepy thumbnail why is that
getting recommended to me
what
it's the Joker but the title is about
The Witcher yeah I don't even want to
try to uh I'm not even gonna try to
figure that one out man
not even gonna try to figure it out
okay now one more thing
before I forget
there was a post from the account that
James said wasn't official but they
posted a different trailer
oh man it's got like the Twitter
compression
so I mean it's this is clearly
officially made
but I don't know where where it was
originally posted
[Music]
that's funny
whoa
stupid bike
oh that's just gonna make it mad
I'm a dragon
[Music]
foreign
incarcerated
oh that was kind of a cool effect right
there
[Music]
dragon's like all right
they're capable I'm done
I'm done
[Music]
gonna hop on out of here
so that one's more just like a an action
sequence
showing off a little action scene in the
game okay wait now here's is this
another
oh it's this is the one
what do they have access to this if it's
not official
yeah that's the same one though
all right let me make sure we've gotten
all of the official
news let me check in with you guys here
first to make sure I haven't missed
anything
you haven't had to save anyone yet being
a lifeguard hey that's a good thing
though that's a good thing
bow ties are absolutely cool Dr sherbet
I agree
tag cheaters with the secret Azkaban tag
yeah and it's like you you just can't
escape they're Dementors everywhere you
go so it's like you can move around but
you just can't get out that would be so
funny dude
oh that'd be so funny
all right so let's catch up a little bit
more here on the other uh because they
have all these little updates down here
just to give even more
info about the game which for me is like
someone who's coming in as
a noob
haven't played it at all
I feel like a lot of this is going to be
useful so
your journey to master the magic starts
here you invite it to attend
dual enthrilling multiplayer real-time
matches browse the dazzling shops of
Diagon Alley solve Mysteries as you roam
the school Halls show off your moves at
the dance club explore the Forbidden
Forest and more in this new card
collection and role-playing game
all right then we have Master the magic
oh man let's just look let's just look
at
uh okay we'll read through these first
and then I just want to look through all
of that artwork a little bit closer
love the bow ties but hate the spiders
right right
yeah I wonder if they're gonna put an
Arachnophobia mode people gonna start
asking for that I don't feel like those
spiders are as scary as the Hogwarts
Legacy ones but
what do I know
all right so Master powerful spells and
charms like Expelliarmus and wingardium
leviosis summon unicorns Cornish Pixies
and many other Fantastic Beasts unleash
powerful artifacts such as the monster
book of monsters against your opponents
all right then you have collect cards
add 70 plus spell cards to your spell
book and level them up strategically
build decks to suit your playstyle and
face any challenge counter your
opponent's spells and PVP duels and
Ascend as a topped ranked contender in
the dueling Club
explore Hogwarts roam around the halls
of Hogwarts or fly over the school on
your broom
so wait what is it
I actually don't know that I've seen
much of a
I don't know that I've seen an actual
shot of what does it actually look like
to move around in this game
is it more like like is it is it top
down like this like when I'm walking
around Hogwarts is it third person like
is it behind the camera
or is my I mean is my character like in
front of the
camera and the camera's like behind
yeah this this game is mobile
and at some point PC as well we just
it's kind of unclear on when exactly
it's coming to PC
especially in the US it's not been made
clear yet when it is
mm-hmm
hey no problem Lauren good to see you it
was good to catch up have a good one
we will see you next time
is the game open world
sword
Echo might be able to answer it third
person top down sort of okay so kind of
like a top down
you can move around the castle and fly
through the grounds okay and then I'm
assuming like go to Diagon Alley
I'm assuming
but I don't know if you can do that
anytime
anytime you want
you're hesitant at trying out because
because Hogwarts mystery was a sore
disappointment
I mean at least that's that's a good
thing about being free right is you can
just try it and if it's like eh
this isn't what I was hoping for then
then it's no uh no cost to you
you didn't think you'd like the art
style at first it has grown on you yeah
I mean I'm
I like the art style pretty much from
the get-go
and he's just so different like it's
just it's very different from what we've
seen it reminds me of the tie
Harry Potter covers
you guys ever seen these man
the Thai Harry Potter book covers
look at this dude
that's for the first book right there
love that
that's book two
book three oh that one might be my
favorite look at the werewolf up there
dude they make serious look evil though
don't they
he looks like some evil vampire right
there that the grin on his face
then you got number four
number five oh that one's pretty good
too look at Umbridge
oh man
number six
I'm just so used to Mary Grand Prix
growing up in the U.S like with with
those versions of the books like I just
have such a clear image of all of those
in my head
but these
these are really good and then book
seven
oh man like these are just so full of
I don't know man there's there's so much
on these
and it's like it doesn't give anything
away
but after like after reading the book
you would notice so many little things
like look right there you've got you've
got Gryffindor with the uh the sword
you've got the Elder one right there in
the middle the badger holding the cup
and then let's see there's got to be a
Ravenclaw yeah there's uh eagle with the
diadem
and then a snake with the locket oh so
good man
oh I didn't even see this before but
Ron's holding the time Turner
oh I didn't even know a couple of
illustrations from inside the books I've
actually never looked at this part
that must be Madame Maxime right there
oh my gosh look at that beautiful
illustration on the front of the box set
I have a larger high-res
version of that showcases like all these
oh there's fluffy look at that
Slytherin down there oh that's so cool
but yeah I digress I digress the art
style though it it definitely reminds me
of those
you had no idea they existed yeah
there's a lot of uh there's so many
Harry Potter book covers from all the
different translations I actually
started a series on that years ago of
like I was gonna try to rank every
like do a little tier list and in each
video I would rank them like add a new
one and discuss it break it down and
rank them
and then I just like I ran out of steam
I started it
I think I did the UK and US edition
switch
sorry to the UK folks but the majority I
like the some some I like the UK
versions better but most I like the US
ones better
oh if I had to pick a favorite
oh man which one would it be my favorite
cover for the US
Harry Potter books
there's something I really like about it
would probably be Half Blood Prince
I really like half blood princes but I
like I like all of them for I like all
of them
I know the art those tie covers I've
thought about buying them before like
and having them shipped over here just
as a collector's item just a display
because they look so good
oh zodiac that would be a fun stream
good call
very good call all right where are we at
though we were
let's see I think we I know we read that
one
learn new charms okay I don't think we
read this one
so roam around the halls of Hogwarts own
your magical skills and classes fellow
which is Wizards learn new charms try
your hand at divination practice your
defense against the dark arts test your
knowledge of History of Magic and more
test your knowledge of History of Magic
I wonder what that's about like are
there little quizzes that we can do in
the game
that could be kind of cool
duel with players so the trailer focused
a little bit on this test your abilities
and strategy and exciting 1v1 or 2v2
duels build your deck bring along your
companions and step into the dueling
Club clever positioning of your Wizard
or witch strategic card selection and
team synergies can turn the course of a
match
brew potions of course they're gonna
have potions in here as well learn the
subtle science and exact art of potion
making face unspeakable dangers and
gather rare ingredients found in the
deepest corners of the Forbidden Forest
combine them into potions to restore
life sharpen your wits and heighten your
senses
battle creatures tame an angry
hippogriff with your magic skills
but how it works
bow keep hordes of gnomes at Bay with
the help of your mates Dodge the Flaming
Rage of a Hungarian horntail Dragon but
don't be phased you'll have some
Fantastic Beasts on your side to Aid as
well and then join your house take part
in the Sorting Hat ceremony right after
your arrival at Hogwarts will you walk
the path of Courage wisdom ambition or
loyalty hang out in the common rooms
with your fellow house members decorate
your dorm room and wear your colors with
pride
foreign
huge quiz the faster you oh my gosh I
love it that is awesome
the faster you answer the more the more
uh points you get
sorry retro if you already answered when
are you going live again I have no idea
Jake
I have no idea I'm not on a uh a set
like streaming schedule right now I'd
like to start streaming regularly
every week but
it just takes so long to make videos
and we're really trying to to get more
videos out on the channel on the channel
lately
so it all depends on you know how many I
can get through each week and then I
dude I haven't played I haven't really
been playing a lot of games lately man
I've been posting my if you guys are not
following our let's play Channel if you
enjoy watching long form let's plays
uh go check out our let's play Channel
right now but I've been posting our
Zelda playthroughs on there and
I actually haven't even played
um the story I've done a bunch of shrine
and other things I've done a bunch of
those things
but I haven't progressed the story
anymore I'm like so far behind we took
uh we went on vacation and then
I got behind on all that my son had his
end of the year baseball stuff end of
the year schooling
and then all the stuff going on with the
channel man it's just been so busy I
haven't even had that much time to game
lately that uh the lies of P demo that I
I posted a video about this week which
is doing well by the way thank you guys
for your support on that video
um I'm really liking the how that game
is shaping up was not on my radar at all
and they put out just a phenomenal demo
but yeah that was the last thing I
played in a while
so I've I've got to get through Zelda
man I was having such a good time with
that game
such a good time with it I mean we were
rolling we were just we were really
putting a lot of time I think I just got
burnt out I was streaming so much
we were streaming just
a ridiculous amount of hours over on
Twitch and doing a doing let's plays for
for Zelda all the while
um some of the classes can be fun and
part of the team events as well
interesting
very interesting
streaming star field I don't even know
if my PC can run Starfield
I was looking I mean it can't but I'm
like I think I'm actually slightly below
the recommended specs I'm above the
minimum but I believe I'm slightly below
the recommended and I only have one PC
so I couldn't like
I don't think I'll be streaming that
game
by vacation you mean testing quitted
Champions no no we were uh we were down
in Florida for uh for a bit
there's pigs to prove it Dustin
picks to prove it
above minimum that's all you need to
play it but not to play in stream
I need to be I would have to stream it
he was asking about streaming
I'll be totally honest with you guys
I I want to watch the trailer the big uh
whatever that thing is that they did on
Starfield
but just from like what I've seen like
what people are saying online like I
almost feel like it's too big for me to
even think about playing right now
foreign
like
because I I know
how I how I am with games like that like
when I get in it
oh man and then you guys I mean I'm
sitting here talking about how much I
love I I love tears of the Kingdom
absolutely love it
but man you just get busy and then then
you you miss a few days and it's like oh
my gosh everybody's beating this game no
I haven't even so like I before I play
any game like I have to be tears of the
Kingdom for sure
there are so many good games coming out
this year it's actually kind of crazy
Starfield will consume your life you've
been falling asleep to the direct every
night
that's the thing
that's the thing it would be that type
of game
but I haven't really like
the only Bethesda game that I've ever
really got what's your history Dustin
with like Bethesda games have do you
like play them all
because the only one that I've really
gotten into is Skyrim and it's one of my
favorite games I love Skyrim Platinum
did on the PS3
but
I've I like I think they're really good
but I like like Fallout for example I've
never gotten into Fallout as much as uh
other people have I've tried it played
it like okay this is cool I enjoy it I
like Skyrim better just like the setting
better
but yeah I want to watch that and
actually that was my plan that was what
we were gonna do tonight actually Dustin
you would have been happy about that
I was gonna have a stream just what
reacting to that whole direct and then
we got this announcement today and I was
like oh man we got to do this instead
we gotta do this instead
nah I'm not an Xbox guy uh Jake
I'm a PlayStation and Nintendo guy in
very very rarely a PC guy
but these days like man the more I'm
like I'm trying to slowly Whittle down
just to like
because the older you get guys you
realize like you're not gonna have time
this is a sad thought
you're not going to have time to play
every game that you want to play
isn't that sad
at least that's true for me because
there are so many games I want to play
there's just so many good games
like 2023 is absolutely
and it's already been an incredible year
for games and then you look at what we
still have coming out
dude everybody's going crazy about this
Final Fantasy demo
I haven't played a Final Fantasy game in
so long but people are talking up
talking up that demo like it is just
absolutely incredible and anybody who
tries that instantly pre-orders the game
so you got that you got star field
which people are people like Dustin over
here are losing their minds over it
you got Spider-Man 2
you got Mortal Kombat I know Christie's
excited for that you got this Liza P
game which I'm telling you guys don't
sleep on it
you got a A little title called
Assassin's Creed I think that's probably
gonna sell a couple of copies
one or two maybe
and then if you're a Wizarding World Fan
we've got we've got this and potentially
quidditch champions
I still don't know what I feel about
release day for quidditch champions
I could see them doing uh in my most
recent video I said maybe they do like a
beta like a public beta
then I could see it releasing this year
but if they if they want to just like
fully polish absolutely everything then
who knows could still be a ways away
demo is amazing wait which game are you
talking about Christy the Final Fantasy
one
look at that see the oh we got the all
caps too that's whatever everybody who
play I gotta play that demo but the game
comes out next
or this week does it come out this week
I need to play that demo
I'm playing more the lies a p demo
I'm so glad I played that because that
wasn't on my radar at all
yeah it comes out this Thursday
comes out this Thursday
oh Dr sherbet I I I was so close to
hitting by on the collector's edition
I got in like I
I could have gotten it and I was like
it's been that much on the collectors
I'm already running out of room to put
my collector's things
ah
so yeah I resisted it was difficult
though it was difficult because that
that Venom statue is
fire
um
what were we saying though Christy was
saying uh Final Fantasy demo okay yeah
yeah that's what everybody says
I'll be living Stark field vicariously
through everyone else Jenny I that is
that's kind of how I feel
right now now maybe I watched this
Direct
which I haven't yet I haven't watched
any of it maybe I watched that and I'm
like okay I gotta play this
like now
but
there's part of me that's just like eh
I'm gonna I'm gonna see I'm gonna see
what other people create and make
and how how much time people spend
in this game Dustin Starfield is your
top game you've been waiting for since
they trademarked the term years ago oh
my gosh dude wait so what about uh are
you just like big into the
are you a big fan of um
like Mass Effect no man's Sky have you
played those games
because I loved Mass Effect
I I enjoyed that quite a bit
but I I never really got into no man's
Sky almost did almost did
oh so it's like it's like the space the
space stuff for you I got you I gotcha
love Mass Effect no man's sky was good
okay yeah I like I like Mass Effect a
lot
now Dustin is it right that
is Starfield only first person
which I know I'm keeping this up and
we've just like completely moved on from
this but
let me see if I can find a star field
trailer
I'm just gonna find like I don't want to
watch the whole
okay so this official
official Gameplay trailer 309. let's
watch this
the open world RPG with the choices ah
okay
foreign
oh I'm planning on watching it just not
tonight
the time stamp in the video later in the
unknown
oh wait I think I did I think I did
watch this the Wonder is
get that 4K baby
so is this like what no man's sky was
supposed to be
is that is that what's gonna happen here
[Music]
yeah I keep it like I hear all this
thousand Planet stuff
it's like wait I've heard this before
25 years in the making
we're all here because we're okay wait
what do they mean by that 25 years of
the making Dustin no way they traded
Martha it's 25 years ago right
committed to the biggest question of all
oh
you're part of constellation now
part of our family Dustin's like by the
end of the direct you're going to be
buying a new GPU
to play and stream the game
oh wow okay hold up hold up hold up like
look at this
this shot right here
I'm like I'm so there I'm so there I
love
this is like cyberpunk Vibes which I
still haven't played cyberpunk which I
hear is actually a pretty darn good game
now
but this is like that uh oh dude what's
the movie Blade Runner
what's going on with this guy though
stand all that is at work here
the whole final group in the stars to be
unraveling this mystery
is that Han Solo
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for another great
secret the universe is asking us to
unravel
they got the music down too let me tell
you like they
Dustin like freaking out with the all
caps
I mean I gotta say the music that just
that like
they're going with that epic they want
you to just like jump up out of your
chair man and start clapping
that's what they want JP what is up dude
welcome in
so it does have uh somebody said it does
have first and third person okay I don't
know why somebody said uh I read
somewhere somebody's like it's only
first person it's like what no way human
settlements throughout the Galaxy and we
got house in the house let's go house
it's been a while dude welcome in good
to see you
[Applause]
oh yeah there we go that was
showed us right there there's third
person
wait what is this
some some Hatchet
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
freaking Microsoft why'd you have to buy
them it should be on PS5
I swear I'm bitter
man I played uh Skyrim on PS3 which ran
just it ran so bad on PS3 frame rate was
that was terrible
and somehow I still Platinum through all
that game
played it all the way through
oh semi this dot is Doc been complaining
about that
oh my gosh because like I'm not
buying an Xbox the one
I would I would just upgrade my GPU this
is so vast
which which I mean I gotta say man like
video editing it's been it's I feel like
it's been kind of slowing down a little
bit
you might might need to be time to look
into an upgrade man
might need to be time to look into an
upgrade
no I do I do want to play it at some
point for sure
finally somebody who's with you for once
whoa wait we got did I see Noob
somebody's saying Noob is noob in the
house there's Noob oh my gosh we got
house in the house we got Noob here
uh jzt said so excited we know oh man
you weren't the only one Jay-Z I almost
I almost I was like this close to buying
no man's sky like the night before it
launched
oh it was so close
one of my friends was talking about it
and and we were both kind of on the fins
he he went through and did it and I did
I'm pretty sure man I'm pretty sure I
haven't talked to him in a while
but I'm pretty sure that he he got a
reef
oh my gosh dude which I to be fair I've
heard that no man's sky in in a similar
vein is cyberpunk is is now a very a fun
a fun game
so I don't want to hate on no man's sky
but yeah at launch
I did see that Jenny about the
collecting sandwich
I did see that I'm just gonna let this
play through again here
another option
I've seen some people uh online talking
about I hear G -force now
has actually been improving a lot and
this game is going to be
on GeForce now so that's like the cloud
streaming
and the person that I was talking to it
was um oh what's his name from the attic
fellow content creator
I was asking him what's the input lag
like because anytime I've ever tried any
kind of cloud gaming the input lag is
just it's too much for me like I'm very
susceptible to it I can I can notice it
really easily like the time you press
the button until you see the action on
screen
and he was saying it's like non-existent
which has me like hmm because he's on a
Mac he's gonna be playing Starfield on a
Mac but through GeForce now
you can play it on like a super high-end
PC
if you have a good internet connection
that's the downside of any cloud gaming
Alicia with the seven months uh Alicia
what is up
can't stay great to see you streaming
again hope you're all having a great
time Alicia we've had a good night we've
had a great night we talked a lot about
Harry Potter magic awake and we watched
the new trailer when went through all
that information
and now we're in in our Randomness Zone
you know how it goes
we're in the randomness Zone at this
point
I'll say this much I'll say this if if
it was coming to PS5 I think I would buy
a day one
I think I would buy a day one if it was
on PS5
whatever lies at the end of this road
although it's not even
I don't want to be a frame rate
um snob
but I saw where it's only going to run
at 30 on consoles it's kind of annoying
not even an OP you know
and I say that as someone who just told
you guys I played Skyrim
on the three Platinum did oh man if you
guys were
I don't know if if any of you played
Skyrim at launch they actually patched
it and it got a lot better but at
launched oh my God it had so many it had
so many issues
so many frame rate issues Alicia thank
you so much for the
seven months very much appreciate it
Series S though would look Series S
would actually is worse than what I've
got National I've got a 2060 super
which can run it
honestly I should I should just see how
it runs
because I'm only on actually I have a
1440 monitor but
um I mean as long as I could get
60. I don't need to get like the hundred
and you know 100 plus Hertz on it with
Xbox game pass
um
but um what else was I gonna say
during it there was something else I was
gonna say
I'm just going to leave this up because
I love that background dude that site
that website is so cool
it is so good you got the collector's
edition Christy oh man the one that
comes with like the watch
somebody sent me uh sent me a
a DM about that I was like that looks so
nice
GPU is like 600 oh I already read that
one yeah I think I I what I have now is
probably better than the series s easily
better than Series S but um see the
thing is I could sell my current GPU
and see then you can put that towards
see there you go there you put that
toward a new one
no but I kid you not you guys I really
have star fuel aside I really have been
thinking about because I a few years ago
I kind of got on this timeline of like
staggering my upgrades like one year I
upgraded my GPU and then two years later
I upgraded my CPU
now I'm in it's in that time where it's
my GPU is definitely the next thing that
needs to be upgraded because like
everything else is pretty solid I got a
good CPU my Ram I'm at 32 now
got a two terabyte SSD in there so it's
like the GPU is really the
the biggest thing I still need to do
move I just right here I just got to
your comment about no man's Sky oh my
gosh I played no man's sky in the
beginning cried a little
place
Alicia I honestly know nothing about
Harry Potter you're not the only one so
many people have said that
so many people have said that and you
know I mean like
it's not a good sign when like our crowd
the people who watch the streams here
and we're really looking forward looking
forward to Hogwarts Legacy it's not the
best sign but it's free to play so I
mean once it comes out it's like anybody
can try download it and try it
Alicia with a super chat as well going
back to sleep now only managed to join
because your cat woke you up oh my
goodness good night Alicia good night I
hope you can get back to sleep quickly
he will be on the game past day one yeah
I saw that too the uh
Starfield
pathetic Bethesda has always been about
better fidelity
well you know what Dustin it it's 2023
man
it's 20 23.
video games they just
they're objectively better
when they run
at higher frame rates
it's just true
what are you gonna be planning on Dustin
series X
[Music]
if it was on Playstation you would have
got the constellation Edition oh like
the collectors
interesting astral you like Sci-Fi
movies and shows but you hardly play
Sci-Fi games
I don't play I I don't feel like I play
a lot of space Centric games
I mean Metroid but that's you know
metroid's like its own thing it's not
really
I mean it isn't space and you're going
to different planets but it's not so
much like a space exploration like a lot
of these
foreign
you gotta upgrade your GPU for this
you're at minimum with a 1070. yeah I
think the uh
let's look this up here
Starfield recommended specs
bring back the music too
is this accurate Windows Central
yeah so like I'm good with the minimum
pin 70 TI is minimum
but then you're recommended
yeah it's either recommended an RTX
2080.
and so I think the 2060 super is
basically the equivalent of
it's like right around a 2070.
I'm good here
good here good here
most cases recommended specs will enable
you to turn settings up to medium or
high
so yeah my monitor's 1440 which is going
to be a little more taxing so I I bet I
could probably run it at medium 1440.
and probably get pretty solid frame
rates
here's how you can identify what you
have if you're not sure
full up on meds time for sleep in
recovery stormy thank you for being here
hope you feel better
take a steady consistent 30 over
inconsistent
oh yeah I mean if it's like constantly
dropping that's
that's a problem too
but you know with the uh
see
I'm not even gonna get into it
I'm like to to go to where I wanted to
go I would have to get so technical
but there is a
if there were more 120 hertz displays
out there
there's like a scaling technique that
you can actually do
40 frames per second
and but it only works well if it's like
120 hertz this but it's like I said I
don't want to get in all the technical
aspect of it but I was like that would
that would have been a good compromise
but I guess they figured not a not
enough people have
120 hertz displays
but I don't know man like I feel like
frame rates in
this generation I feel like they've most
companies have been doing a good job of
including
uh performance modes
and running pretty pretty stable like
Hogwarts Legacy just as like one of the
most recent examples for me ran great
now
I'm also loving the heck out of Zelda
which
the the little the little system that
could you know
the Nintendo switch Still Still chugging
along
and it feels good it's it's a it's a
stable 30. so it feels good
so I'm sure Starfield will feel fine on
like series X but
still sad to me as someone who is since
the since the first time I could ever I
remember playing Metroid Prime
Metroid Prime was definitely 60 FPS but
I want to say that Super Smash Brothers
I'm trying to remember which game was
like the first game where I was like
what what is this
because some people and if you don't
notice it
more power to you more power to you be
glad that you don't notice it because
there are so many people who are like I
can't even tell a difference
even people that play a lot of games are
like I don't even tell a difference
between the frame rate it's not that big
of a deal
I don't know man if it's like if it's
like eyes if it's like just what you're
what you tolerate and what you don't
tolerate but I'll never forget like
playing games like Smash Brothers Melee
and Metroid Prime for the first time and
being like
and at that time I was like I didn't
know how to explain I was like this
feels so
smooth
like what what is this what is this
smoothness going on here
and it's because they run it run at
higher frame rates
but yeah tail tail as old as time you
know the balance between
frame rate and and fidelity
[Music]
your series X gotcha
doc shouldn't be I mean doc if you guys
are talking about doctor disrespect like
wait doc who are you talking about are
we talking about Dr sherbet we talking
about doctor disrespect
I was like wait what are we talking
about two different docs here
Draco need to start getting ready to
leave work and get home oh for sure
Draco you were a big help dude I know
I'm a little behind on comments so if
you're already gone sorry I missed that
but yes you're a very big help thank you
very much appreciate it
foreign
yeah JP yeah it's it's pretty pretty
close to a 2070.
gosh this
this music you guys
[Music]
this music
what what what is this
like we're trying to stay we're trying
to stay awake and chat here
imagine if I just like Phil Phil sleep
on stream
just like good night guys thank you for
being here yeah
it's been fun
24-hour stream good night
just like Nestle up right here right
here next to the here we go
get like one of those travel pillows
oh my goodness first Dream back come on
oh my goodness let's see
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna pick one called
surprise me
here we go oh and and we get Christmas
for lovers
you cannot make this up
oh my goodness we got a 10 from Dustin
oh my goodness Dustin thank you so much
join our DND campaign Dustin now you've
never played DND
I have never played
he's like I don't care join
oh my goodness wait I still gotta know
if you guys were talking about uh
[Music]
how how do we get this
okay let's try to let's roll it in let's
roll it let's try again
this one's called Carolina Mud
okay
I mean at least it's not putting me to
sleep
or should I say Carolina Mud
Carolina Mud ladies and gentlemen that's
what we're listening to now
[Music]
I'm pretty sure now you guys were not
talking about doctor disrespect which
makes that
hilarious
[Music]
you live in South Carolina
Dustin
you are the Dust
I know you
oh my gosh
[Music]
they didn't get the family-friendly memo
come on now
[Music]
but I can't do it I just can't do it
let's see let's uh
let's try let's try one more category
here I'm gonna try one more category
oh here we go I know this this one right
here stream beats all right
okay
all right we're like we're a hacker I'm
like go back to that star healed scene
you know the neon City
I'm just sitting at my PC all the lights
are out you just see the reflection
shining on my face that's where we're at
right now
but this this is better than like
putting me to sleep
Dustin thank you so much for the 10
though appreciate it
Jay
Rock Jay Rossi what is up welcome in
dude
Jay Rossi
are you gonna be playing Star field
I bet J Ross is gonna gonna try
Starfield
I know you're an Xbox guy Rossi oh I
knew it we were just talking about it
Miami Vice yes
upbeat and use the sunny beats playlist
I've never heard of that one
[Music]
this is one that uh James recommended to
me pretzel rocks
and like the first month it was great
and then I don't know if like my free
trial or something ran out but all the
a lot of the ones that I kept using
started having these locks on them
now I play chill EDM and we get
whatever that was that was putting us to
sleep earlier
Noob your character is Loki got a
Mischief deception fire you forgot the
last thing
upbeat I'm gonna have to look that one
up
music wants you to go play Animal
Crossing in the roaches
oh my gosh I don't know what my Island
would look like if I hopped back in
there
it would be very very bad I would have
just like the maximum number of weeds be
weeds everywhere that we'd have to pick
up
you're squishy and trouble
I just don't I don't have the time for d
d man I see how long
like when James does the the freaking
nerd streams and they're doing d d
it's like oh my gosh these go on for so
long I just don't have time for it
just do not have the time
I mean like I'm already telling you guys
now I have no time for
like when you're trying to make content
and
do streams
it's so hard
to keep up
to keep up with everything that I want
to do oh there's so many videos I want
to make right now
and then I'm also just like I really
would like to just go stream Zelda for
five hours
oh yeah this is so much better this is
stream beats now we're
we're good now I mean stream beats is
usually pretty solid but sometimes even
those get like I'm like what
is this
but yeah I think I'm gonna do some more
uh streams over here on YouTube whenever
we do stream again
foreign
but I'm thinking I'm also thinking about
I can't decide if I want to do gameplay
streams here
or gameplay streams on our let's play
Channel
oh is it too loud let me turn it down
oh yeah we I did leave it
there we go
that's crazy that it was loud it was at
35 percent
and then I also have it as a minus eight
in my obs
wait hold on we got multiple DND games
going on
Dr sherbet's the dungeon master oh wait
I thought L1 was the dungeon master
you guys finish did you guys finish that
one
or is Elwyn doing a separate one
it doesn't with all the talk about FPS
playing zeld on the switch outdated and
loving it
I don't love that aspect though I
already I made a video on that
it's so annoying
it would be it would be so much better
whenever they release the switch 2 and
they're like hey here's
tears of the Kingdom remastered everyone
because it'll happen
you did a one shot
I'm glad I'm glad Dustin's explained I
don't one shot was
and so now Dr Sherman is the is the
master
oh my goodness
did you guys stream that one
see I haven't even I haven't even been
like watching anybody's streams lately I
haven't even I'm just like
I'm telling you guys man I like wake up
I start scripting out videos I start
researching videos
I guess research income you know comes
before start scripting out videos I
record the videos I edit the videos I
post the videos the day it's the end of
the day
well you haven't streamed it yet the
next one will be streamed okay
so you guys have been playing you just
haven't streamed anything yet
Christy stay away from the chaos
oh my gosh you guys now you guys are
like
you talk in another language now
you owe some pirates wait what
are we at are we over over 100 likes
that's not what we do
James just can't come in and do that
can't just come in and hijack things
like that
oh I'm kidding
that was pretty funny
um
that doesn't know James can
if anybody can James James can yeah
I did zoom out my camera a little bit
more
because we we used to have uh push-ups
over on Twitch as a uh
like a thing people could redeem
hold on let me see let me try something
we're we're in the we're in the off the
rails portion of the stream at this
point
the regulars know this if you're if you
stumbled into this and you're new and
you're like
this guy's got Harry Potter magic
awakened as the thumbnail
on YouTube here's what you can do you
can you can like go pause it and you can
rewind so go ahead go ahead and do that
and you'll and you'll see when we talked
about magic Awakening now we're just
we're in the off the rail section of the
stream okay
all right
I'm gonna see if you guys can actually
because I would like to bring the
push-ups back
let's see if you guys can see me at all
when we go here
I gotta move my chair back further
[Music]
you could just see the top
hold on hold on let me I'm gonna go all
the way
[Music]
just barely
and see like the pirouettes I'm gonna be
partially cut off let's see
dude how awesome is this shirt though
how awesome is this shirt
all right here's what we can do though
I mean you guys I can't be like
partially cut off for the pureette
come on now what's the fun in that if
we're gonna do it we gotta do it right
you know
all right so let me go to my
I can do this with the webcam
let's see is that going to be too high
oh yeah there we go there we go
all right pure Ritz here we go
we didn't say we didn't say multiple
Pirates we said we said one
that's what we said
that's what James said we never even
said it he said it and he's a friend I
like him so we'll go with it
dude if you guys could just we have like
so little room right here
yes I'm making excuses and delaying
okay wait hold on James always he always
has like this right he does that's kind
of like
the last thing I want to do is just like
bash into my wall back here
Rio here we go
boom
chair is back
10 out of 10 uh I'll take it thank you
thank you
Staying Alive oh my gosh I'm not like
slap Happy enough for that I've not been
streaming long enough for that
that have to be
that would have to be like if I ever did
a 24 hour stream
and just
get like deep into the night you know
like three four a.m where it's you're
all it's like is it morning is it night
I I don't know
after I've had like a couple of Cherry
Coke Zeros and maybe some uh
I don't know man like some kind of uh
what's something like high really just
like Sour Patch Kids
then you might get me in a slap Happy
enough mood that I would be like
let's just go crazy
getting Wild on those Cherry Cokes man
that's right
I know the pirouettes
such a fun thing I'm so mad when we were
out in uh La I want it
dude this is kind of got some like
80s retro right here
some 80s retro Vibes on this one
they have on stream elements they have
entire
stream packages
that look like 80s retro Style
which is kind of funny because all of my
overlays and everything I've always went
more like futuristic
than that
[Music]
I'm like that Dustin
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh yeah we got a lot I've got quite a
few Cherry Cokes out there but
you know what I thought would be a fun
24 hour stream if we ever did one
[Music]
okay so if you guys haven't seen our
video yet on I bought every Harry Potter
video game ever
check out that video dude one of my I
spent so much time on that video one of
the
one of the few videos I've ever made
where I've actually recorded over
I mean like weeks of of different
footage
so I thought a fun follow-up to that
video would be trying to play
every game
in 24 hours and then make a follow-up
video I played every Harry Potter video
game in 24 hours
but it's like okay what we would have to
set up some sort of criteria for
what qualifies as playing you know
because if it's just it's just booting
it up and like
running doing one spell and then leaving
that wouldn't really
hold on let's let's
do math here
let's do some math
because we would need to have bathroom
breaks in there and we would need to
have you know like time to stop and eat
and chat
so the games that I bought that are
that are like physical Harry Potter
games they're 39 total games
now that doesn't include like the mobile
games
so like hold on I'm gonna put these out
to the side
as like possibilities Hogwarts mystery
um magic awakened
and then if it's
whenever I make the video if it's out by
the in quidditch Champion so that would
be like three more games
let me turn this music back down
getting a little crazy up in here
that's what that's kind of what I was
thinking half an hour a game
so if we did 39 games
and we did let's say we did 30 minutes
each
that's 1 000 170
hours that's 19 and a half hours
that would be
and then if we wanted to do Hogwarts
mystery magic awaken and quidditch
champions
that'd be three more games so that would
give us like time to eat and take
bathroom breaks in between
oh my gosh
so yeah if we did every game
oh dude you know what else I would need
to account for
I would need to account for like
switching out the equipment
because there are so many so many
different
systems that we would need to be
swapping out I mean some of them I could
just play
on my PC
through emulation but
like um like Wonder book book of potions
Harry Potter connect
oh my goodness dude
so and and do a subathon JP imagine
oh imagine
then there's Harry Potter for connect
that would have to be like our
like our our game when we're when we're
starting to hit that wall
and we just gotta like get get up and
get moving
Harry Potter connect would have to be
the one at that point to get us through
it
hey Roger
welcome in Roger what is up dude
good to see you
I know it's been a while Roger it's been
a while
I've been trying to make out a schedule
for how many videos I want to make per
week how many streams I want to do per
week
because now I mean we're we're just now
kind of
settling into that
post Hogwarts Legacy time
because now that the PS4 versions are
out there's not really going to be
anything for a while I I would be
shocked if we got any kind of big
announcements before the switch version
um
but yeah I was thinking about doing some
more gameplay streams let me ask you
guys here right now
let me ask the people here right now
for watching
I know a lot of you watch whether we're
on Twitch or whether we're on YouTube
what are the preferences
as as a viewer
as a viewer like where where do you
enjoy watching more
because I'll be honest with you guys
like twitch has been making some weird
decisions lately that are
frustrating a lot of creators
and I just keep going back to our
original plan we were gonna stream here
this was the plan
and then Hogwarts Legacy started doing
the drops and so it's like ah I should
stream over there
paleo pies dude I saw somebody playing
that
was it you it might have been you
might have been I don't I just saw it in
my feed like I said I've barely even
watched streams but I saw I saw it over
in my feed somebody was playing that
twit Ellen said twitch viewer engagement
more
see you know what I've never tried Owen
I've never tried streaming on YouTube
like during the day like during an
afternoon
I've never done that
JP said uh YouTube
Dr sherbet said twitch
we did a poll
this shocked me we did a poll on not on
our YouTube channel we did a poll on
Twitter before Hogwarts Legacy ever came
out and said where do you guys want to
stream the game and it was like 75 in
favor of YouTube which shocked me
shocked me I did not think YouTube would
win and and win by a comfortable margin
and then I like basically didn't listen
to any of people who voted because when
Hogwarts Legacy did the drops
so yeah I mean twitch definitely has
they like have the the atmosphere if
that makes sense like in terms of the
integration with with all the things
like like sound alerts and all the extra
emoji and the moderation tools like all
that
twitch has
what they don't have as much is well
it's a better it's it's a worse um like
Revenue split when you get subs over
there it's 50 50 versus on YouTube when
you guys choose to use a membership here
it's 70 in favor of the creator
um and then YouTube like it stays on my
channel
so I don't know if you guys have looked
back at some of our past live streams
this was the most crazy thing to me
we did a stream shortly after Hogwarts
Legacy launched we did a live stream
over here
and the uh
the thumbnail is something just like
doing side quests or completing side
quests
and whenever we had our one Hogwarts
Legacy video go crazy that video for
whatever reason YouTube picked that
video to start recommending to people
that were watching that other video and
that video like blew up that old live
stream video
that type of thing
is impossible on Twitch
just impossible
and then you have other videos that like
you know you'll do a live stream and
that's it like you never get another
view on it it's
so but then sometimes you'll have it's
so it's so interesting
sound alerts Channel points yeah
Asheville said either one Whatever Jenny
said for me Twitch for streamers Maybe
YouTube
oh good point Dustin a lot of people do
like watching on mobile twitch is better
for mobile very end oh well then Logan
just said Logan said YouTube is less
resource and intensive hmm
sign me up sell t-shirts wait what kind
of t-shirts are you talking about we do
have uh we do have an official retro
wreck into our merch
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
[Music]
Roger you watch Mostly on Twitch watch
wherever like the interactions twitch
offers
oh that's weird Blue Moon that's
unfortunate
twitch refuses to notify me up your
streams
there's more for viewers to do that is a
good way of putting there's more for
viewers to do on Twitch true
but there's more for your video to do
on YouTube
Noob I watched much mostly on YouTube
okay
yeah when I feel like you guys yeah
because I feel like At first a lot of
you guys the moderators were saying
YouTube and then once once we started
using twitch a little more
you guys started to kind of see see the
benefits
Noah welcome in Noah which game are you
talking about
Noah we've been talking about a lot of
games tonight
I appreciate that Moon spark appreciate
it
yeah that's that's exactly it JP at the
end of the day that's the thing that
that's that's really it's it's an
unfortunate thing
because I mean at the end of the day
YouTube like
how about kick you guys let's go over to
kick man
oh my gosh
um
like YouTube they could they could make
so many improvements
they can make so many improvements
and just like make a lot of Headway in
the streaming game which they've been
like for years they keep saying they're
going to but I to your point JP like I
think
YouTube understands something that
twitch
I don't think is figured out just yet
like YouTube do they always make
decisions that are in favor of the
Creator no not every time not always but
at the end of the day I think YouTube
they truly understand their whole
business model like relies on keeping
creators happy they they get that
and they hire people they hire good
people to put in certain roles that
that communicate and work with creators
on things like that and then twitch is
just like
it feels like they're asleep at the
wheel a lot of times it's like wait what
you guys realize if if you didn't have
streamers you
you wouldn't have anything
you know everybody always complains
about ads on Twitch too and I'm like I'm
sorry I can't do anything about it
unless you sub
I can't do anything about it
[Music]
yeah that was kind of originally the
plan Dustin
is I was gonna do um
I was gonna keep like our normal
Tuesday live chatting hanging out video
game news discussion all that that show
is gonna just stay here on YouTube and
then game play on
on Twitch
but here lately I'm just like
I should just do I should just do
YouTube for a while see how it goes
oh Hogwarts Legacy Noah oh I loved it I
loved it
platinumed it finally we did get the
platinum trophy
took it took a little bit
Joe hey what's up Joe
hey goodbye Joe I know I also saw uh
Maria says I watch more on YouTube
and then jzt didn't even know about
twitch but you've heard about it
yeah for sure pros and cons for both and
it's like it's not like you can't
we can't try out both
you'd watched me on kick
I I have I haven't I made an account
over there
they s for those of you who don't like
follow all the streaming stuff
this website called Kick signed the
biggest streamer on Twitch
the biggest streamer
to a deal worth 100 million dollars
a two-year a two-year deal
dude that's like Pro that's pro athlete
money two years
and it's not it's non-exclusive which is
kind of strange to me
but yeah I don't think I'm gonna be
going over to kick
not for a while
if we all yeah yeah if we organize like
a a mass uh we just take like this this
little
this little Wizarding World Community we
formed and get everybody to start
streaming over there
oh man that's funny
that's exactly right Owen that's that's
the biggest thing YouTube needs to do
yep yep yep yep
which it's like it seems like it would
be such an easy thing to do but I don't
know I'm not like I'm not that kind of
engineer I have no idea
it's like it's such a weird
discoverability question
like on Twitch there is no
discoverability unless you're live
on YouTube there's very little
discoverability when you're live unless
somebody's already been
like exposed to you and watch some of
your videos or some of your streams
before
but yeah it's so weird to me that
there's not just like
like just even make it the URL like if
you go to youtube.com gaming
just make that look like the twitch
homepage but with
with YouTube lives like if you go right
now it shows it shows all the games and
then you scroll down
but yeah then it's it's not like it's
not all live stuff so is your top live
games but not like creators see what
happens if you hit view all yeah still
still just the games
and I know that people have to be
suggesting these types of things
adds a glitch for you on Twitch they'll
freeze and you can't watch anything oh
my gosh
Community is so generous with Subs
usually if someone says I know and I
kind of
sometimes I'm like
the person who
if they're like abusing that it kind of
makes me mad when somebody's just like
coming in they're like oh these people
are really generous in here I'm just
gonna be like
oh my gosh the ads and they're just
complaining over and over
and then one of you super nice awesome
people's like here have a sub
JP you followed me up oh that's too
funny
you followed me on Kik
forever remember you were the first one
you were the first one
gamer Knights uh
subscribing to the channel
thank you so much gamer night
I actually thought I had that program to
say something different but
now I know
oh I played watched all the Zelda game
t-shirt or the Harry Potter games
that would that would actually be a good
shirt I played every Harry Potter game
in 24 hours
happy yoga day is it really yoga day
hey we got two kick followers uh oh uh
oh we're already building up our the
kick Following over there let's go
I appreciate that Nike yeah I mean
that's that's why I'm asking you guys
that's what I'm asking
ah
but yeah I might try to test out
I've thought about doing some just like
strictly gameplay streams on our
uh retro wrecking tour let's play
Channel
just to kind of draw in a few more
people over there
because I'm sort of hesitant to put too
much gameplay I don't know dude I don't
pretend to be an expert on the YouTube
algorithm
it's like sometimes I'm like I think I
understand
and then other days I'm like okay I'm
worried is this hurting my channel
like every time after a live stream this
is kind of weird
there will always be like you click on
the live stream video
like if I click on whenever we stream
Spider-Man
that video was a minus one in terms of
subscribers we didn't add any
subscribers like strictly on that video
by the way did you guys seriously
you guys seriously lied about the likes
no way
no way you guys lied about the likes
just to get the pureed
oh dude that is hmm
wow
I see how it is
no more pirates for you chat
no more
none
we're done
Roger too many streaming apps I know
right
he said 100
nope yeah that's like the Pirates are
done
they will never happen again
man we just um
I ain't even mad chat I ain't even mad I
love you guys
I feel like I asked and I think somebody
may have said
no or something
and I just like forgot about it moved on
um what was I gonna say there was
something I was gonna say about uh
oh my gosh what were we just talking
about before that
too many streaming apps
all eight so all they said was for you
guys to like that I would be a red
that's funny
[Music]
streaming on the let's play
yeah I don't know it's it's gone but
it's fine
it's all good oh yeah and I was talking
about the like how just when you think
you understand the
the like how the YouTube algorithm works
and all that
and then you have a video that like that
live stream I was telling you guys about
that YouTube just out of nowhere
it's like oh hey let's promote this live
stream video to people
it's funny how that works sometimes
all right but I think this is gonna be
it for me man I think it's gonna be it
appreciate you guys hanging out
appreciate all the the gifted
memberships all the re-upping of
memberships
very much appreciated guys
he kept losing every race oh my gosh
Rush
James and those beans dude
so you guys notice I've very smartly
I've never bought any beans
that's why I can just be like guys I I
don't have any beans I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry what do you want me to do
I can't I'm not gonna go buy beans right
now
not just gonna go buy them
[Music]
I'm not just gonna go get beans
that's
oh my gosh I'm just gonna it's gonna be
like overflowing with beans
100 likes and I eat three beans yeah you
guys you guys just making up stuff now
no like the next time you guys
I tell you guys we're doing something
and then we unlock it
it's gonna be like not so fast we
already did the pure red so that was
your that makes up for it
that makes up for it
if I decide to stream pod racing
oh man okay I know a lot of you watched
Star Wars so let's real quick Star Wars
story before we wrap up we've always
gotta get a nice we inevitably end up at
Star Wars at some point in every stream
I feel like so my kids have just started
really getting into Star Wars recently I
don't know what it was
my son maybe some some kids were talking
about it at school or something
and we had just been talking about it
several weeks ago on a live stream about
like when what's the right age and I was
like he's he's
the right age
and then he came home from school one
day and asked about it I was like
I'm ready for this moment I'm ready for
it I I asked we know we know we're
starting with the original trilogy
so we did we we watched he's watched uh
episodes four episodes five episode six
and then today he watched episode one
so yeah we're we're making our way
through and he he really he's really
enjoying it my youngest is watching he
kind of like comes in and out of the
room a little bit he'll watch when
there's a lightsaber fight we're like
hey they're fighting and he'll run in
love Star Wars since he since you were
six Rossi yeah my oldest is he just
turned nine and then my youngest is five
so
they they've already passed Christy or
caught up to Christy no way
oh wait hold on what did you say Jay-Z
let me see here
another HP fan Channel much different
coverage
yeah what I'm not sure what you mean
like you just like you you wanted to
shout them out or you wanted to say like
they have some good content ideas
that you'd like to see us try
so yeah now we're ready for Attack of
the Clones
watching Phantom Menace I didn't watch
the whole thing with him today but I was
kind of in and out
and yeah it's
it's rough
it's rough but it wasn't as like bad as
I remember
for a kid I feel like I mean he he
seemed to really like it like I feel
like it's it's a kids movie you know
the first Phantom Menace it's it was
designed to be a kids movie like you got
jar jars just the comic relief I mean
he's just silly he's just doing goofy
things
but it's got some pretty good like the
lightsaber fight at the end is pretty
good
the music oh my gosh what's that one
called Duel of the Fates
that's a pretty good that's pretty good
and then I mean the pod racing scene
it's
oh man
the pot the pod racing is cool
Duel of Fates
you love jar jar he's your spirit animal
so I'm curious to see how I feel about
attack of the Clones
oh wait Christy hasn't seen it I was
about to say something okay I won't say
anything else I won't say anything
it's so funny man like seeing how people
look at the Star Wars movies
and how they I don't know like everybody
pretty much agrees that the original
Three are pretty solid
and then I thought everybody liked the
newer ones
but now I feel like people hate on those
a lot too
so I'm like wait are we supposed to like
this one I I enjoyed the uh
oh my gosh I can't even remember all the
names at this point
um
oh what was it episode
seven
Christy was shocked to see you and me
won
oh man Force awakens thank you Rossi
yeah like I like that one a lot I
thought that was solid
uh and then the next one I didn't love
not a fan of what let's just say what
they did with Luke not not a big fan of
that and then the last one like I just
barely even remember I need to re-watch
that one I barely remember that one
oh I do there was one really
hilarious scene that wasn't supposed to
be hilarious but I almost laughed in the
theater
let's just say that the powers of the
force it's just like
they just keep growing man the things
that the force can do
Dustin you're gonna start a war
that's our cue Noob that's our cue to
sign out baby
that is our Q all right guys that's my
Star Wars story for tonight
we'll be back soon I promise it will not
be as long
it will not be as long
but yeah I'm gonna try to figure out
where we want to do our next uh gameplay
stream and I really I want to play some
Zelda
I'm itching to get back into Zelda
so guys appreciate you all hanging out
hope you all have a wonderful wonderful
rest of your evening uh which I never
did see I don't think I saw that comment
from
from Jay-Z about the other Harry Potter
Creator I don't know if you're still
here jzt
for pump for that
wait what time is that Direct
is the direct
could we stream that
depends on the time of day if I'm in a
stream
oh so it's early
10 a.m eastern time oh no wait he said
7 A.M PT so that'd be 10 a.m Eastern
oh
might be a fun way to start the morning
40 minutes oh we might do a chat we
might do it
we might do it
all right then that means I better hop
off so I can get to sleep here shortly
which is really like several hours later
after I get some more work done
oh man
all right guys thank you all for being
here
hope you have a fantastic rest of your
day good to see you glad to hear
everybody's doing well
spread lumos man keep spreading lumos
into this world it's a world that needs
a lot of it it needs a lot of it
as always
oh my gosh I forgot
forgot to start the Stream
letting people know that we're just a
dad
who love schemes and the stories they
tell
we'll remember next time we'll remember
as always thank you all so much for
watching
we'll talk to you again soon I don't
know what this was I don't know it just
it's like a little a little sign off
thing
goodbye
goodbye something like that
[Music]